[Music]
foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview for a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive and it's
time to see what's making the headlines
with the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire and the columnist for the
article Ali Mirage there they are
standing by for us they'll be with us
until just before midnight but first
let's have a look at what's on some of
those front pages the eye leads with the
German and American government's
decision to send tanks to Ukraine and
move the paper calls an escalation of
the war in response to this news the
male proclaims finally the West unites
to defend freedom
and the mirror also leads with the world
United against evil covering the Allies
plans to send huge Military Support
in actual times hears that the American
aircraft firm Lockheed Martin is
prepared to produce more of its F-16
fighter jets if they're deemed necessary
to take part in the conflict
the Metro has a word of the Metropolitan
Police Commissioner Sir Mark rowley's
admission that the public can expect to
see two or three of his officers charged
with serious crimes every week over the
coming months
the guardian reports that the
investigation into complaints of
bullying by the Deputy Prime Minister
Dominic Robb is more wide-ranging than
previously known with more than two
dozen civil servants alleging he
mistreated them he has always denied any
wrongdoing
while the express leads on the cost of
living crisis highlighting the death of
a pensioner from hypothermia who was
worried about the cost of soaring energy
bills
the telegraph meanwhile covers criticism
of the post-brexit trade plans which the
chairman of Marx and Spencer has called
baffling and overbearing
and the star Ponders the prospect of
sending nuclear-powered Rockets to Mars
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you're seeing on your screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and of course we're joined tonight by
Kevin McGuire and Ali Mirage a very good
evening to you both great to see you
lots to talk about and a good mix of
Stories on the front pages as we've seen
them so far but certainly many of them
of course leading on this decision by
America and Germany today to send battle
tanks to Ukraine Uh Kevin to you first
the front page of the eye talks about
this in some detail that President Biden
insists the decision to send American
Abrams is not meant to heighten the war
but of course there is a concern for
president zielinski over the delivery
time of these tanks
no absolutely uh and your tanks are the
most dominant uh story on the front
pages and tomorrow's papers and uh
zielinski wants them as quickly as as
possible
um military people are talking about
between three and six months it could be
late spring uh early summer before the
tanks arrive and our operation because
it's not like having a new car delivered
and you just get in the get in it and
drive away you've got to be trained how
to operate what a really complex uh
pieces of uh of equipment but it's
interesting the iGo uh and talking about
uh hold back Putin rather than winning a
decisive Victory they also quote Lord
West who is a labor peer now former head
of the royal Navy chief of the defense
staff same Putin's Bluff has been called
while at the same time the Kremlin are
saying look these tanks are going to
burn well a lot of uh Russian t-72s have
uh have burned so it does feel like an
escalation and the war is heightened uh
whatever Biden uh says yeah uh
absolutely Kevin and Ali to you at the
front page of Kevin's newspaper The
Daily Mirror also leading with this
story the headline the world United
against evil and certainly it does seem
that that decision from America uh to
send their Abram tanks has potentially
unlocked uh Germany's decision to send
the leopard twos uh for a while there
when they had that meeting in Ramstein
it didn't seem that there was
necessarily A united front among
International Partners but that is what
President Biden is now maintaining we
are thoroughly United
well sunny I think it's very important
uh it was very important for Olive
Schultz the German Chancellor
to be able to tell his people and to
sell to his people that this is
completely United and all the key allies
particularly the US uh was on board and
is putting its money where its mouth is
in terms of sending Abram's tax now
there's been a lot of talk in recent
days about the Abrams Tanks uh being
much bigger very difficult to maneuver
they need a lot of support and it was
really the leopard two tanks that The
ukrainians Wanted there are plenty of
them in Europe the Germans have uh many
of them and also the Germans hold the
keys to the export licenses that allow
other people in Europe particularly the
Polish uh to send their tanks uh to
Ukraine and that was not forthcoming
until now the reason it wasn't
forthcoming from well F Schultz was
really very simple he knows that 40 to
45 percent of his own population are
very nervous about sending uh tanks to
Ukraine and the reason they're nervous
is two reasons one there's a historical
reluctance following the Second World
War for understandable reasons to be at
the Forefront of military action and
secondly you look at the um the
potential of dealing with a nuclear
power uh that where whether where the
thing could escalate so it was very
worrying for him so he understands now
that uh the the US has done the right
thing they're sending Abrams Tanks he
can give this united front impression
and Military experts are saying that the
leper two tanks are very they're much
faster than any other tank out there
they travel at about 72 kilometers an
hour and have a better stabilization uh
than the uh Russian tanks they're up
against the t-72s t90s which means that
they can actually fire on at speed which
will give them a superior would give the
ukrainians a superior advantage on the
battlefield so it's a seismic change for
the ukrainians but it is an escalation I
mean that's absolutely clear and the
next thing is uh whether uh f-16s are
going to be the next thing that they're
going to be asked for and provided now
at the moment that's not the case but if
you go about six months any offensive
weapon whatsoever particularly tanks
were completely off the table so you can
see how this is uh escalating and
creeping and this is all done because
there's a potential Spring offensive
from Russia uh that's expected to come
and the ukrainians want to be well
equipped understandably uh to tackle
that so I think I think uh Olive Schultz
has eventually done the right thing but
I think it was quite sensible for him to
be cautious and uh get other allies on
board before he made that move yeah the
Germans consistently said they didn't
want it to just be their German tanks uh
on the ground in Ukraine uh to the front
page of the Daily Mail Uh Kevin their
headline finally the West unites uh to
defend Freedom talking about uh Boris
Johnson's rallying cry for allies to end
their dithering I mean it's not clear
what involvement if any Boris Johnson's
had in any of this but certainly the UK
was the first country to offer its tanks
yeah I think I think it's pretty clear
why to involve in Boris Johnson's had
and it's a CD Pro I don't think he's got
any clout with Biden and the and the U.S
uh decision to send uh Abrams or uh
Schultz decided to send uh leopard or
Poland it's just the male trying to put
itself and uh Boris Johnson is back
championing and cheerleading for as it
falls out of uh love with Rishi sunaka
who never wanted to be prime minister in
the first place it favored Liz trust
back in the day before that 44 Day
Disaster so uh but the West has actually
been pretty United uh for for some time
there's just been disagreements or quite
what level of support is is is given I
mean Hungary maybe uh questionable
because of its links uh with uh with
Russia and you know the far-right
government there in Putin and so on but
I think the West is pretty pretty United
and the world I'm not sure about because
you've got think that China and India
aren't backing Ukraine and South Africa
not so there are large parts of the
world that maybe they're not sympathetic
to Putin but they're not backing uh
Ukraine either but I quite like the
cheek of the the male put itself and
Johnson
it just here it ain't the case you've
got to say neither had any influence on
this decision well it's interesting you
say that but he
interesting that he's still sort of
playing some sort of role Ally uh what's
your take on all of that I mean he's
absolutely adored in Ukraine uh members
of the public tell you that regularly
when you're over there voluntarily
sometimes it's the only words in English
that they they know we love Boris
Johnson
um but it's interesting isn't it that
he's still out there speaking to
president zielinski
well I mean he's got a very good
relationship with zelenski we understand
that a number of Ukrainian babies being
born will be named Boris uh which uh
clearly is understandable given the fact
that Boris Johnson was at the Forefront
of uh stepping up right from the outset
uh to support Ukraine and obviously
Boris Johnson uh still dreams of his
second coming uh like his great hero
Winston Churchill uh as prime minister I
can't particularly see it happening
myself he's got a very marginal seat in
Uxbridge which he's uh said he will
contest he's not doing a chicken run to
a safe seat which is something I guess I
think we should give him credit for that
but certainly he's a demographic the
demographics of that seat are changing
um and I was brought up around there and
it is changing quite rapidly so if he
holds on uh which is a big if then then
fine who knows what could happen you can
never write him off but frankly I think
that the the soap opera that we had to
endure uh under his leadership uh
frankly was a period that the Tory party
should get over and move on from he's
got many virtual issues he's got a witty
Turner phrase he writes decent articles
he gives good speeches but the serious
business of hard-headed governance uh
unfortunately was not one of his
strengths okay and just a brief look um
at the guardian before we go to a Break
um their front page also uh running uh
this story from a U.S perspective
President Biden approving uh those tanks
for Ukraine certainly uh Kevin it is
hoped uh it's speculated that this could
be something of a game changer for this
war
yeah it it could all it could be but it
might not be because it's going to be
very difficult to dislodge those Russian
forces which have dug in I think a
better bet if something happens to uh to
Putin that uh people internally turn
against him but the guardian point out
because the US is sending 31 uh tanks uh
the UK is sending 14 Germany's sending
14 and I think that just shows you how
now the real the real supplier of
weapons in the world is by for Ukraine
it's by far the US with uh Britain and
Germany about level pegging in in Europe
we sometimes get carried away in the UK
thinking it's uh you know Britain
leading the way it's not it's now really
the Americans who are arming the
ukrainians welcome back you're watching
the Press preview you and With Me Now
Kevin McGuire and Ali Mirage to review a
couple more of the front pages uh to you
first uh Kevin uh Nadim zahawi uh his
job's still hanging in the balances uh
conservative party uh chair but he must
be pretty relieved he's been pushed off
a lot of the front pages today uh by
these battle tanks but he's still
amusing brief on the front page of the
eye
now exactly and then you have to turn to
page eight and Brew the eyes one of the
few papers that has him on the on the
front and I suspect the whole strategy
of zwai and surac is just to try and
pattern down the hatches and ride out
the storm uh and I hope we'd uh hope it
goes away
um
it'd probably suit labor in some ways if
that happened if he stayed as uh
consider a party chair because there's
no doubt he's damaged goods he'll never
be effective again how can he go around
making speeches about the great joys of
the conservative government uh when
there is this big question mark hanging
over his taxation but it would certainly
you're right the tank the tanks have
rolled in and they've pushed him off the
front page it's you know it's not made I
thought a possible attempt to defend him
today but I think Stormer got it right
when he said look you're just hopelessly
weak because uh he is he he's not strong
enough to suck him I mean that is the
truth you know pocket-sized prime
minister just a quick sort of strong
just a quick thought from you Ali on on
this um of course Rishi sunak uh
maintaining today that he wants to wait
for this investigation uh to be finished
by his independent ethics advisor
yeah look I I think uh Rishi sunak has
got the most difficult job in politics
right now he needs just like a hole in
the head he was trying to talk about
money for mental health he was trying to
talk about the leveling up funds that
were doled out to 111 areas and he's got
this to deal with
um it's deeply deeply uh unfortunate
very bad timing and looks appalling uh
for the party there's an investigation
going on that's fine uh but the politics
of it the Optics of it are really really
poor and kirst armor said you know is
the is the job too big for issue a prime
minister's questions today and it caught
me old-fashioned but there was something
in uh public life called the London
principles where you have honesty
transparency leadership we need a bit
more of that from top level politicians
really Ali Kevin we'll have to leave it
there much more in the next hour thanks
very much indeed